in this course Seth golden will teach
you how to Google like a pro knowing how
to craft the perfect queries can make a
huge impact on your efficiency and
overall experience Seth has been using
Google to help him develop software for
many years and he's currently a CS
student at Yale University are you
effective at searching the web you
access the internet every single day
after spending so much time searching do
you consider yourself to be a pro
okay did you know that you can force
Google to search exactly for a
particular term by putting double quotes
around a word or phrase that quote is a
search operator and it's extremely
powerful maybe you already knew that but
there's a lot more where that came from
in this video
searching is a skill not often taught in
school or boot camps yet many people
from programmers just getting started to
senior Engineers heavily rely on it if
you're spending a third of your time
researching information that means a
hefty chunk of your job is just being
great with Google
I'd argue it's among the most important
skills a programmer can bring to the
table
but with millions of results to sit
through most people struggle to pick out
the most relevant
the reality is you're not always going
to know everything you will run into
some bug you can't figure out
maybe you decide to learn a new
programming language or how to develop a
feature I guarantee you'll use search to
find relevant documentation and articles
and potentially to help understand them
becoming better at search will make a
massive difference in your productivity
and efficiency whether you're a software
developer or not
and if you're an online learner the
number one reason why people fail to
complete curricula such as that
available on free code Camp is because
they get stuck and can't figure out
their problem the internet has almost
all the answers but you need to be able
to extract them
in this video course I'm going to
explain how Google works underneath the
hood I'll discuss how to form the best
queries a fancy word for questions and
identify the best results and I'm going
to introduce you to around 30 to 40
search operators that will power up your
searches to the next level
you'll learn to use these operators to
augment your existing searches and
instead of randomly clicking on the
first view of millions of results you'll
be able to search for fewer higher
quality answers
while the info in this video is focused
on Google as per the title much of it
will apply to other popular search
engines such as Bing DuckDuckGo Baidu
Yahoo Brave kagi and more I'm also going
to touch on more specialized and
alternative search options towards the
end this video does have a programming
Ben but I'm going to try and keep it as
approachable as possible even if it only
offers you a couple new Tools in your
search Arsenal this video could have a
massive impact on your work simply
because of how much you use search
stop being a passive web searcher let's
get started
[Music]
if you're watching this video you
probably use Google a lot but that's
pretty easy for me to predict everyone
does the average person makes three to
four Google searches per day
as programmers we're super users often
searching anywhere from 2 to 20 times
that I certainly fall into that camp
personally
there are many awesome resources out
there stack Overflow medium dev.2 and of
course free code Camp which are
accessible via a simple search
a common misconception is that you're
searching the web in reality you're
searching Google's index of the web in
many ways Google is like the Hub station
that connects us to all the different
parts of the internet where we hang out
for many people that internet is Google
and Facebook
I'm going to help you understand how
Google search works behind the scenes
knowing why some sites rank higher than
others may help you more effectively
find what you're looking for
if you're already familiar with how
Google search works or more interested
in ways that you can phrase search
queries feel free to skip to the next
part
the original algorithm that Google used
to order web pages was known as pagerank
developed in 1996 by the founders of
Google Sergey Brin and Larry Page the
concept is basically what if we applied
how citations work in Academia to the
entire internet
in the research world the more citations
a paper has the more important and
relevant it's considered to be pagerank
similarly theorized that many websites
would link the most important Pages a
concept called backlinks it examines how
many quality internal and external links
a web page has to estimate its
importance if a lot of high quality
sites link to some new page that page
might be high quality too when this
algorithm was applied to a commercial
search engine which was originally
called backrub it was able to surface
results that were more useful to
Consumers pagerank is actually public
domain even if you're not familiar with
some of the math it's a pretty
interesting read
while pagerank is still considered as a
factor when ordering search results
today it's not quite the same as in the
original paper plus it's now in
combination with several other stronger
signals
so how does this work today
here's where your search results
currently come from
first Google crawls the web that means
it algorithmically discovers and
compiles new and updated web pages into
a massive internal database of millions
and billions of sites
there's also a few ways search engines
like Google can find a new web page such
as sending Bots also known as spiders to
visit them following links from known
Pages people can also submit Pages for
Google to index which is called using a
site map
Google renders the web page during this
process which includes running
JavaScript in order to ensure that all
content is visible and keep track of the
information on each web page
now that Google has this massive
registry of information they need to
organize it somehow
the content in newly crawled web pages
is analyzed and used for indexing if
you're familiar with webdev this
includes looking at Hidden metadata such
as title tags in the HTML
Google then tries to filter out low
quality content this is really important
as the reason you probably keep coming
back to Google is because you find it
reliably helpful
search engines determine the quality of
content through signals which are
thousands of characteristics of web
pages that align with what humans might
interpret as high quality or reliable
pagerank which I discussed before is one
of those signals speed and web vitals
are also strongly considered
another is rankbrand which uses AI to
conduct semantic search or make sense of
the connections between links and
content and web pages
Google stated that rankbrain learns to
improve over time and was at least at
one point the third most important
signal
there are also thousands of search
quality raters who have the job of
ensuring these signals are working as
intended
after quality filtering Google clusters
web pages with similar information one
web page is selected to best represent
each group of similar Pages this is what
you see in the search results
Google's algorithm is still somewhat
Secret
in part because of the Black Box nature
of AI and in part to try and avoid
people gaming the system
so what happens when you search
something
whenever you enter a query Google does
its best to use some of the signals I
discussed before and interpret what your
search means this can be tricky as like
humans search engines have difficulty in
identifying things like tone from text
alone
according to Google it took five years
to develop their system for spelling
mistakes and synonym matching but it's
now used in around thirty percent of
searches so I'd say it's probably worth
it
after Google has an idea of the meaning
of your search they then scan their
database for the web pages they believe
will be most relevant
relevancy is influenced by literally
hundreds of factors such as your
location and language
because Google's registry is so massive
there will often be millions of results
relevant to your search
those pages are ranked programmatically
based on their relevance and then served
to you usually in a few milliseconds
let's say I search for science
internships some information Google has
on me from my last three months of usage
my location is at a university
I'm studying computer science I read The
Verge TechCrunch and free code camp and
three of my most visited websites are
GitHub free codecamp and stack overflow
Google was able to use this context in
combination with my query Which is
popular from my area and determined that
what I actually want to see information
on is not science internships but
computer science internships and you can
actually test how this works from any
location
now that you have a better idea of how
Google serves web pages let's see how
you can form better queries
[Music]
time to discuss the ultimate question
for getting the most out of Google what
should you actually type in the search
box how can we take the inordinate
number of results and filter them down
to what you truly want
be thoughtful searching efficiently is
about finding the balance between
concise and descriptive queries begin
with something simple like what is X or
how did y depending on the results of
your search you can reformat your
phrasing
use what we learned about how Google
works whenever you make a search put
yourself in the mindset of the person
writing your answer
when rephrasing your question consider
what words might they include in the
title or content of your ideal web page
what synonyms or key phrases
for instance don't search I'm confused
by when I should use semicolons Instead
try when to use semicolons or semicolon
grammar tips
being more precise in your queries
usually translates to more relevant
results
let's say you love to bake how to bake
the best apple pie returns 214 Million
results
a more specific search such as best
Dutch apple pie recipe has under 8
million that are closer to what I'm
craving
as a patient you might search what's the
best place to treat heart disease where
a more effective search could be best
hospital for Pediatric heart transplant
and if you're debugging there's dozens
of things you can try here
still it's possible to be too specific
consider what you actually want to learn
and avoid including redundant or
unnecessary terms in your query
let's say I need to know how to execute
a piece of code when a widget loads in
flutter for a loading screen for example
instead of searching flutter async login
widget I can search flutter async widget
while specifying loading might be more
specific it can also cause Google to
return fewer quality examples of what I
really want to know which is the concept
of asynchronous widgets in flutter
think about how complex your query is
can you break it down into smaller
questions try to distill the core issue
of your search into the set of terms
that you use Google is often more
effective when retrieving information
for one question at a time
watch your words when choosing words to
include in a query there's a few things
to keep in mind
first every word is Meaningful as a
single word can make a massive impact on
the results you receive for example Dove
a Dove d Dove and Dove chocolate will
all return very different results in the
last case it's very clear you're
searching for the chocolate brand but
even small words like a or V inform
Google that you're not searching for the
beauty products
to be safe type words that commonly
appear next to each other in the way
that you'd expect to see them French
horn not horn French
spelling punctuation and capitalization
do not matter
free code Camp free code camp in all
caps and free code camp and snake case
or title case all return the exact same
results
Sergey Brin once said his goal was for
Google to know what you're searching for
before you do we haven't yet fully
reached that point but it can certainly
help you get a question from your head
into the search bar a lot faster
understanding how Google generates
autocompletion can give you an idea of
topics similar to what you're
researching it can help you complete
your queries more quickly Google States
their autocomplete future reduces
overall typing by around 25 which adds
up to about 200 years worth of typing
each day
predictions are generated by comparing
the characters that have been entered
with what you've searched before and
what other people in your region have
searched Google also has systems for
predicting portions of a search rather
than the entire query their autocomplete
engine will automatically shift from one
mode to the other
let's say you're confused by the complex
IOS app development pipeline if you
search tutorial for how to install Apple
developer certificates Google may help
finish the second part of that phrase as
an extra tip if you can't remember a
word when using autocomplete you can
replace it with an underscore as a
wildcard word
if you want to get more unbiased results
you can open up an incognito tab in
Chrome that's accomplished with Ctrl
shift n this will lock you out of all
accounts and enable you to find results
without the important influence of your
personal search history
these tips will hopefully help you ask
better questions but even very specific
searches can offer millions of results
to sift through and the next part I'll
discuss how you can pick out the most
helpful ones
[Music]
thank you
throughout the rest of this video I'm
going to cover how to use keywords and
operators to filter your results
techniques features keyboard shortcuts
Etc these will all help you obtain more
helpful and relevant results but
ultimately determining the most accurate
and useful information is going to be up
to you
many people blindly trust the first
three results will be best the number
one position on the results page gets a
third of all traffic but successful
online research requires critical
thinking the first search result the
first stack Overflow answer those won't
always be accurate or helpful let's
examine the search results page or serp
the one with all the Blue Links
each result on the search results page
has a title URL and description also
known as the abstract snippet as I
mentioned before these are ranked by
relevance
don't stop with the top result instead
of randomly flicking on the first few
links from the millions of results try
this
look at the entire page and consider the
context surrounding the question you had
or the concept you're trying to learn
remember what you previously thought
your ideal search result would include
and it's title word content now see if
any of the results on the serp match
that info in their titles or
descriptions reading results carefully
is the most important part of this
entire process
the descriptions of each result often
have relevant bolded terms in them if I
search how to audit a class online I'll
see the top result has bolded auditing a
course
if you see words or unfamiliar with in a
title or description don't skip that
result you can open another Tab and look
up the definition and then return to
your research
another essential tool that Google
Engineers recommend for finding an
answer or getting a handle on a topic is
called lateral browsing when I'm
researching a topic or debugging some
code I'll often control click on several
results at once this will open them in
new tabs for me to peruse swapping
between is needed to cross-reference
content when scanning through your
search results take note of top level
domain names or tlds these are the
highest level of abstraction for domain
name systems or the DNS and noted as the
ending of each domain name tlds are
important as a way of gauging reputation
authenticity or authority
in the United States sites for
educational institutions will commonly
end with DOT edu this is generally an
easy way to identify more reputable
sources it also applies for other tlds
such as.gov for government websites you
can often pick a website's Source based
on their domain ending with a country
code for instance sites based in Spain
might end with es and sites in India
often end with Dot in
notably you don't need to live in a
country to use their country code as a
domain ending dot IO meant to refer to
sites in the British Indian Ocean
territory has been heavily adopted by
computer scientists because it can refer
to input output and because it sounds
cool
internationally many tlds combine a
country code with endings such as dot
geo.br.co.in which are the equivalent of
dot gov and.com domains respectively
you may come across information while
searching the web that you question
some info can change significantly based
on context if you search for the number
of programmers in the world that number
will change based on how the source
defines a programmer
don't accept that anything you read on
the Internet is authoritatively accurate
Google does their best to filter out Bad
actors but stuff slips through the
cracks additionally even people with
good intentions often make it difficult
to verify their statements if I said 73
of programmers go to bed before midnight
how can you best confirm that ideally I
have provided a source but I didn't so
as far as you know I just pulled that
number out of my butt who's considered a
programmer time zone success so midnight
where
as an inquisitive person you can start
by conducting another search of your own
but take care to not include the answer
in your query that's an easy way to have
confirmation bias
if you search for Are there 25 million
programmers in the world chances are
someone in the world has written down or
recorded that statistic you've found it
on the web but that doesn't mean the
numbers right
a search asking JavaScript is the most
popular programming language is likely
to pull up information saying that yeah
people love JavaScript
Instead try and write more General
open-ended queries like most popular
programming language 2022 or how many
programmers in the world
a fantastic way to verify information is
to find several perspectives if multiple
credible sources agree on an answer it's
more likely to be correct check to see
when content was written and where it's
Source from then consider if that makes
sense for the subject matter for
instance an article about a quote
attributed to a person who passed away
long before any references connecting
the two on the web
did you know that the famous line Luke I
am your father is different when set in
Star Wars the line is actually no I am
your father simply searching Luke I am
your father will probably pull up this
result that you can go deeper by
searching for the original script of The
Empire Strikes Back reputable sources
are really important
the new highly cited indicator that
appears on sources that are being used
as a reference for other news outlets is
one feature that helps with this
additionally check if a site you've
discovered in your research has any
reviews or if people have discussed it
and forums like Reddit whenever you're
reading information ask yourself why
might this site not be reputable or
trustworthy
while forums are incredibly useful since
anyone can post take everything set on
stack exchange sites and similar sources
with a grain of salt
Wikipedia though is actually still a
fantastic place to start a search
because there are usually dozens of
curated citations related to your topic
to view
one of the most important parts of
thinking critically while searching the
web is asking yourself effective
questions is there evidence for this is
it always the case what's an alternative
viewpoint
also ask yourself questions about these
questions does that make sense what
assumptions do I make can I break this
down into smaller questions
as humans we're hardwired to dislike
information that conflicts with our
pre-existing beliefs this is one of the
trickier aspects of becoming a pro web
searcher you need to be willing to
accept all answers from trustworthy
sources with an open mind even if it
makes you feel uncomfortable if you are
feeling emotional about an answer
conduct another search to confirm its
validity
but stay skeptical if a piece of
information seems sketchy maybe it is it
can be worth it to see what conflicts of
interest a source may have if a site is
backed by a politically motivated or
extremist organization it's likely that
the authenticity of Journalism of that
source is compromised many sites also
pretend to be affiliated with a
reputable person or organization so
always assess whether what you're
looking at is actually legitimate
an easy way to do that is to do another
query searching who owns
freecodecamp.org will pull up the name
Quincy Larson by reading more about
Quincy perhaps by searching who is
Quincy Larson I can discover that he is
a highly transparent and reputable
person without major conflicts of
interest but wait this video is
published on free codecamp's Channel
which means that I could be biased when
I said that although I promise you
anyone who knows Quincy will back me up
that he's amazing
still it's important to verify that you
can trust not only the platform
information is published on but
individual authors as well
be careful of ellipses and result
descriptions sometimes censuses will be
cut up in a way that's misleading it's
usually a good idea to validate an
answer by clicking on the link and
reading the original text
you can also click on the vertical
ellipses next to a search result title
to see Google's new about Source feature
this will give you information on why
Google thought that that result might be
relevant for you
finally keep in mind that a website's
ranking on your search results page is
not a reflection of its credibility
nutty stuff can be listed as top results
if they're relevant to your query
similarly anything that shows up as an
ad has generally not been evaluated for
accuracy by Google
now that you're an expert at extracting
and validating information from Google
search results I'm going to speak about
some awesome operators that will power
up your queries
thank you
Google has dozens of features called
search operators to improve your
searches they're extremely powerful
filters and utilities mostly focused on
helping you achieve much more specific
and relevant results you've probably
used several without knowing some are
keywords others are special characters
they're mostly case insensitive meaning
it usually doesn't matter if you
capitalize them or not and all can be
used anywhere in your query
Google is updating these on a regular
basis so the list might not be fully
comprehensive at the time you're
watching I have personally tested them
so they should all work at the time of
recording let's Dive In any search term
or phrase will refine results by
attempting to find exact and similar
matches by default it will follow the
steps I outline when discussing how
Google works if you don't want to
remember or reference the following
search operators every time that you
conduct more advanced queries you can
visit google.com Advanced underscore
search for a simple to use interface
foreign
matching operators remember that first
example I mentioned in this video using
double quotes around any term will force
Google to match it exactly I find this
to be among the most useful operators
available
let's say you have some specific word or
phrase such as an error code or a
message you come across while debugging
putting quotes around it will cause
Google to more accurately find the right
stack of report poster GitHub discussion
for example quote flutter end quote app
development tutorials will only find app
development tutorials specific to
flutter you can also use double quotes
to override spelling auto correction
this is especially useful when you're
dealing with names with unusual spelling
or those that are very close to
extremely popular similar searches for
instance if you search my name Seth
golden you're probably going to get a
full page of results for Seth Godin the
famous businessman and author by
specifying quote Seth golden end quote
you'd be able to find my personal site
and blog you can also use this for
specifying a particular author when
searching articles learn from free
courses Seth golden in quotes would
filter by my name
Google will sometimes return results
with the term or topic that you don't
want it happens the minus operator or
exclusion operator when used preceding a
word will filter out any results
containing that word this is awesome you
can use it to easily get rid of all
those past keywords that invade your
search results
because let's say you search for website
tutorial but you don't want it to
include the framework jQuery you can
search website tutorial minus jQuery and
exclude jQuery from your results
sometimes you just need a wild card the
asterisk operator like a diamond
Scrabble tile can be used as a stand-in
for literally any word or phrase I often
use it to replace words that I've
forgotten I can't remember how to spell
or generally to speed up a search Linus
asterisk Linux so return results on
Linus torbolds the creator of git and
Linux more quickly than if I spelled out
his name given that I provided
appropriate context
I find the Wild Card operators
particularly useful though when
debugging often the error message that
I'm given contains a local directory
that will only be relevant to me instead
of pasting that whole block of text into
Google replacing that section of the
error with an asterisk can significantly
improve results this can also be helpful
when trying to find relevant
walkthroughs for confusing homework
questions
often we deal with words that have
multiple meanings but are used in
dramatically different contexts a
Blackberry is both a fruit and a cell
phone a transistor is a processing unit
and a fantastic video game
searching by a word's proximity to
another word using a round and then a
variable number is a highly effective
way to narrow results especially when
the two words don't often appear right
next to each other if Google can't find
any examples of the two words around
each other it's going to revert to
ranking as normal
let's say you're looking for a tutorial
on managing memory and computer
environments manage around for memory is
likely to narrow in on those particular
results by finding any web page
containing an instance of the word
manage within four words of the word
memory
football around 6 ESL will similarly
help me fuzzy search for specifically
European football instead of the
American football results that I would
normally see
notably this particular operator must be
capitalized to function properly
next up date operators whether it's
finding recent stack Overflow answers or
reading a review from the time a movie
was released I constantly want results
from before or after a specific date you
can accomplish this with the before and
after operators simply follow either
with the date in the format year year
month month day day append it to your
query and your set
for example an error message after 2021
0101 will only return results since
January 1st 2021 meaning that I won't
have to sit through outdated answers
you can also choose to only pass a year
such as before 2020 or after 2017.
python courses after 2021 would only
give you recent courses so that you can
be confident that everything's up to
date
but wait I have a start and an end date
in mind well there's two ways you can
approach that you can include both a
before and after operator in your query
or you can use the range operator
ellipses you can find info and
documentation for a less common
programming language such as with
closure 2016.2018
[Music]
you don't just have to use this for
dates any numbers will work for example
top
7.10 facts Apple Computers will find a
top 10 list or top 7 list
the ellipses operator can be a little
finicky though so don't expect this one
to work 100 of the time
[Music]
next up Source operators Google provides
several options to filter by content
type and source
some people joke that Google is a better
search engine for Reddit than Reddit
amusingly enough I have found this to be
often true many sites have periodically
ineffective internal search engines
including hugely popular ones such as
Amazon
I also find that sites like Reddit and
similar forums can have more trustworthy
human responses to my questions than the
average first search result so I often
choose to filter my results by these
sites accordingly
site is extraordinarily powerful because
it allows you to force Google to only
return results from a particular website
a pending site colon freecodecamp.org to
a query will only return results from
free codecamp importantly you can also
use sites with the top level domain
endings or tlds that I discussed earlier
in this video
site.edu will restrict your results to
purely educational resources such as
with berkeley.edu or yale.edu
search followed by a website URL
accomplishes the same thing in most
browsers but I prefer site URL because
it's shorter
on occasion you'll need to search for
PDFs PowerPoints or other documents on
the web to force Google to only display
results that match a particular file
extension you can use EXT or file type
which are functionally identical simply
follow either with an extension such as
txt PDF docs PPT xox CSV ePub Etc in the
format file type colon PDF
I find this operator is super useful in
searching for textbooks academic papers
novels presentations and especially
anything when relating to academic
research
unfortunately file type no longer works
for MP3 files
if you prefer to search the web for news
rather than follow 400 RSS feeds like me
this Source operator is a great way to
specify the site that Google News should
pull from for instance Amazon source
techcruncher source The Verge GitHub
your search results can be extremely
different based on your location well
Google tries to use your current
location by default it's possible that
you'll want to specify somewhere else
in San Francisco will change my results
to be more relevant to the Bay Area even
if I'm searching from the East Coast
I'm a fan of blogging and reading other
people's blogs it's often a more
personal and conversational experience
about Niche topics of your interest
while sub stack and similar providers
have Consolidated a lot of bloggers many
websites and companies still run their
own blogs you can find these through the
blog URL operator which attempts to find
any blog posts under a domain
blog URL google.com will pull out the
blogs under Google's registrar it can be
a little finicky sometimes though
no website is ever able to escape going
down every so often you can utilize the
cache operator to pull Google's cached
or backup saved version of any website
for example I can see all of free
codecamp's articles even if the site is
down by typing cache freecodecamp.org
next up Boolean operators Google
automatically tries to include all the
content within your query
so and is best utilized in combination
with other operators since it doesn't do
anything by itself I'll discuss
combining operators in more detail later
as I just noted Google searches defaults
including everything in your query the
or operator is unique from other
operators as it causes Google to alter
that behavior and increase the number of
search results rather than filtering
some out
using the pipe operator or
A or B you can scan for a or b
you'll get results related to a or b or
importantly both
if I'm interested in multiple variants
of a data science algorithm I can
conduct a search on k-means or k-means
plus plus to return any result it refers
to either
the or operator is also useful when
searching for something that's known by
several names in the American Civil War
the Union Soldiers referred to a
conflict that took place in Virginia as
the Battle of Bull Run but the
Confederate soldiers kept their records
based on waterways and in their records
they called it the battle of Manassas
when searching about this topic Battle
of Bull Run and battle of Manassas each
returns significantly less information
than Battle of Bull Run or battle of
Manassas
as I noted before make sure you
capitalize or or Google might not
recognize it as an operator
[Music]
next up the in operators
these operators can be used to massively
narrow your search results based on the
content included in my page metadata
if you're unfamiliar with web dev by
metadata I mean the URL or website link
and internal information such as the
page title content and anchors
each of these operators has two versions
an in option and an all-in option the
results for both will be similar but all
in will only return results containing
all of the following terms they both
help to ensure that the words you're
looking for will actually be present on
the pages returned as results
websites will often put important
information in the URL of web pages you
can use in url tutorial to only return
tutorials or all in url tutorial python
app for more specificity
remember how the file type operator no
longer works for filtering Out MP3 files
you can actually use the in url operator
as a substitute such as searching for
Lo-Fi in url MP3
the title of a web page is one of the
best ways to tell how relevant it will
be to you in title flutter will only
return websites that refer to flutter
while all in title flutter app tutorial
will have fewer hits
the keyword you're looking for isn't
always included in the title or URL in
those cases in-text and all in text will
have more benefit
anchors are often invisible linkable
section headers of web pages they're
usually indicated by hashtags such as
hashtag hero or hashtag testimonials in
anchor and all in Anchor will help you
identify web pages with such tags
notably these inclusion search operators
are often best used in combination with
each other they help you extract web
pages that might not have been surfaced
otherwise
finally Google provides many utility
operators that you can use to quickly
access all kinds of data I use these all
the time
wondering what a word means Define and
then the word will tell you using
Google's built-in dictionary it'll
likely display in a side panel along
with synonyms Define entrepreneurship
will quickly pull up the definition and
you don't even need to be able to spell
the word properly
related is one of the more interesting
operators the Google offers it returns
websites that are similar to The
Following domain in the format related
colon and then the web page URL
it's useful for breadth of research
particularly when trying to learn
something for instance related
freecodecamp.org will return sites like
codeacademy.org coursera.org
Etc
need to check your public IP address the
unique identifier that allows your
computer to receive information just
enter IP address and Google can display
what it identifies as your public
Internet Protocol
do you know how many pounds are in a
kilogram off the top of your head or how
to convert from Fahrenheit to Celsius or
how many milliliters are in a quart by
using the format X in y Google can
swiftly tell you for example
456 dollars in euros will tell me that
456 dollars is at the time of recording
434.45 in euros
online shopping is huge right now
chances are you probably search Google
to see different places that offer your
item of interest if you're looking for a
specific price you can search 300 with
the dollar sign Android and Google will
attempt to match that
you can also apply the range operator
here and search keyboard dollar sign 10
dot dot dot dollar sign 50.
looking for a social media account of a
friend or content creator instead of
searching their name prepend an at
symbol to their social media handle to
more effectively pull up all their
social accounts
want to immediately know the weather for
any location you can just search the
word weather for your location but to
specify others append the location like
weather colon Bangkok while you might
use apps like Google or Apple Maps or
ways for your mapping needs sometimes
you'll need to search for One while it
Returns the current location by default
you can specify a particular location
like map colon London
there's a new movie out and you want to
go see it while searching the movie
titles usually enough to pull it up if
it's based on a book or something
similar your search might not pull up
exactly what you want using movie
Avengers endgame is then a foolproof way
to get a lot of info about any film
including reviews cast and crew and
nearby show times
fintech person you can see all the
stonks for any ticker by searching
stocks colon and then the appropriate
ticker such as stocks colon Amazon for
immediate information about the price
history of Amazon
there are several other tools you can
access straight from Google's search bar
if you type any math equation Google
will automatically calculate the answer
if you ever need an on-demand clock type
timer or stopwatch to pull one up or
type X minute timer to automatically
start one search for flip a coin or roll
a die when you need to cast a stitch in
time or any other situation when
generating a probability is necessary
you can also pull up a quick reference
tip calculator with tip calculator this
calculator feature can also be useful
for very important factoids like the
number of horns on a unicorn and the
probability of once in a blue moon
together you can use these utilities to
more quickly access everyday information
while they may not be as essential in
the software world they're still going
to help you make better searches in your
day-to-day life
foreign
these are a lot of tools that you can
utilize to filter your searches and
operators become even more powerful when
you're able to combine them effectively
for example how to build an asterisk app
site colon freecodecamp.org minus
flutter will give me results on any kind
of app tutorial except letter on free
codecamp containing the name Quincy
Larson
another helpful combination could
include the site and URL and exclusion
operators you can search site colon
freecodecamp.org minus in url blog to
get all the subdomains except blogs or
you can find insecure pages on a website
using site colon domainname.com where
you fill in the appropriate domain name
minus in URL https
I find combining the wild card and exact
match operators to be very useful
quote python asterisk tutorial end quote
will return any results with python and
tutorial in that order with anything in
between for example python app tutorial
the wildcard operator is also very easy
to include with other operators such as
site and numerl you can use parentheses
to power up your combinations of
operators I commonly use these when
grouping for order of operations with
Boolean operators like or or when using
synonyms if I want to specify a bunch of
synonyms when searching for a resume I
can do that keep in mind that the pipe
operator or or operator are functionally
identical
Google processes and and or operators in
a logical order make sure to use
parentheses when necessary for instance
Python and parentheses JavaScript or
typescript parentheses will be
interpreted as looking for results
including Python and either JavaScript
or typescript alternatively Python and
JavaScript or pipe script will return
results with python and JavaScript or
results with just typescript not in any
way related to python
let's say I'm looking for tutorials on
the language closure by linking together
search operators I'm able to form a
query which gives me only about a
hundred highly focused results
there are practically endless number of
combinations of search operators I
encourage you to consider what will be
most beneficial for your search and mix
and match accordingly
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
next few parts I'm going to discuss
several features specialized search
options and search related tools that
you might find helpful since you've used
Google you're familiar with how to
search for images just type in some
keywords click on the images tab and
voila but what if you already have the
image or in front of it and you need to
figure out what it is or where it's from
Google image search and Google Lens are
two powerful tools to accomplish that
you can access reverse image search by
clicking the camera icon or visiting
images.google.com
upload or drag your image into the
search bar and it will scan the web for
images that look similar for instance I
have this image of some phones and a
yellow background that I pulled off of
unsplash and used in a blog post I can
upload it to reverse image search and
see all the other websites that are
using it as part of their articles these
include five ways the original iPhone
was ahead of its time Apple now has one
billion active iPhones around the world
and these are the top four highest
selling iPhones of all time I can also
filter for other sizes of the image and
photos that are similar plus you can use
the color drop down menu under search
tools to filter photos by color
transparency picture size and animation
effect to find that perfect gif this
also works for faces clip art and line
drawings
reverse image search is useful if you
already have a photo and you're sitting
at a computer but what if there's
something right in front of you that you
want to learn about perhaps a product
you'd like to find online or a location
you're at Google lens is an awesome
relatively new feature which debuted in
2017 and identifies objects in your
camera lens in real time here I'm using
it to take a picture of my desktop
speakers Google Lens quickly identifies
their Logitech speakers and pulls up
search results of their pricing and
availability
you can use Google Lens to search for
homework help or excerpts of books
online and copy text from physical
documents similar to Apple's live text
feature
I'm a particular fan of their real-time
translate function I can point my camera
at a menu in a foreign language and
receive a version in my preferred
language
these image search options may be more
helpful in your daily life than for
software development but they're
incredibly useful tools to have in your
search Arsenal
[Music]
thank you
everything that Google indexes is known
as the visible web but sometimes you
need to delve deeper this is usually
because of the long tail
many people treat Google as the
all-encompassing internet if you can't
find it on Google it simply does not
exist but that's not entirely the case
before anything else make sure the
reason you're not seeing any results
isn't just what you searched
a lot of times the issue is information
retrieval not the indexing of the
information in the first place
if you have a hyper-specific query every
word that you've added makes it more
likely that you've excluded results try
broadening your search and it's possible
the way you're looking for will pop up
while Google tries their best to index
everything that can be useful the web is
a large and complex place and Google's
best efforts to fight spam content can
be missed that may be important in more
Niche scenarios seen in things like
their indexing of large websites with
too many subdirectories or subdomains
and attempting to cut back on duplicate
content Google has in some cases
completely wiped content off their serps
sites like GitHub or offenders here
where some repositories can no longer be
found on Google because they're old or
unused but while Google's better than
ever for the majority of searches and
Niche cases When there's less data to
work with you could even find nothing
in these cases you'll want to consider
trying alternative search options and
specialize in the area that you're
looking for Google actually provides a
few of its own for more Niche areas
Google Scholar is a massive collection
of scholarly literature from the global
scientific community and it is an
amazing research for serious research it
is primarily made up of papers published
in respective journals spanning
everything from biology to Neuroscience
to machine learning and natural language
processing to Legal opinions
it also includes scholarly sites and
content from universities
Scholars particularly useful when
conducting more thorough research on an
academic topic with some major perks
over traditional search
to start it provides links that direct
to the full version of scholarly
articles books and reports
scholar enables you to see the number of
citations papers have where they're
published and any related authors or
Affiliated institutions it also has
built-in options to copy citations and
export bibliographies in formal MOA APA
bibtex format
you can even dive deeper into individual
authors and view their aggregate work
it's similar to other academic search
engines such as papers with code web of
Science and scopus
while the process of entering a query is
the same as with normal search the
results page is a little bit different
if I search natural language processing
you can see that the result blocks now
each contain bibliographic info
this includes the title of the article
The Source the author or authors when it
was published and who it was published
by
some results will even have options to
see the abstract or even download the
full document as a PDF
the version you see in Google Scholar
may not always be the final paper Google
does its best to show the newest freely
available version which often means a
preprint
adding a year restricting by a date
range in your search can be very useful
in getting more recent findings try and
make use of some of the operators we
discussed before including and or
exclusion and exact match operators for
instance Neuroscience author quote Seth
golden end quote 2022 will pull up my
recent paper on analyzing em images or
quote machine learning unquote minus
medicine minus biology will return
results or ml papers that don't have it
to do with those sub areas
Google Scholar is not infallible
citation data is often not fully
comprehensive or up to date using the
verification skills that I discussed
earlier try to check out the original
publisher as well to check your findings
Google also supports a powerful patent
search available at patents.google.com
you can search Google Patent Search or
Google patents advanced search on Google
for more options and filters
using this tool you can find information
on patents searching by title number
inventor signee and more Google
currently keeps track of patents in
North America Europe and Japan it's a
great resource for anyone researching
patent information which may not be
readily available in a general search
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
if you're unfamiliar with common browser
keybinds I'll share a few these are
generally the same across all browsers
and massively increased productivity
replace control with command and ALT
with option if you're using Mac OS
as I mentioned in part 3 control click
opens a link in a new tab
control T opens a new tab
control W closes the current tab
control shift F or alt F focuses the
search bar
control R refreshes the page
Control Alt R hard refreshes the page
from origin
and Ctrl F searches for text within a
web page this last one is super critical
to efficient searching I constantly use
control F to find the content that I'm
seeking on a web page it saves tons of
time that I'd otherwise spend skimming
information that's potentially unrelated
to what I'm looking for knowing these
keyboard shortcuts will hopefully help
you navigate the browser and complete
searches faster
foreign
[Music]
congrats you're now all powered up and
ready to go and get the most out of
Google that puts you ahead of most of
the other 27 million developers in the
world
was that statistic real try and search
for yourself
I encourage you to consider how you can
combine everything that I've discussed
in this video to obtain the best answer
to your question
start with a simple search use specific
terms to narrow Focus but avoid
unnecessary or redundant terms put
yourself in the mindset of the person
writing your answer break down
multi-part queries into several searches
verify your results browse laterally use
search operators and take advantage of
specialized search engines
searches will sometimes be simple other
times you'll be deep in the weeds
online detective work can be hard
my last and most important piece of
advice don't give up it might take two
searches or three or six rephrase your
query and try again
you have access to all of human
knowledge take advantage of it
thank you for listening to this video
course I hope it was of some help to you
after finishing this course do you feel
like your approach search differently
I want to thank the amazing people at
free code Camp who supported the
development of this course additionally
my appreciation goes out to Google
search intern Eric bozen Lincoln Baxter
and several Google Engineers who
requested their names remain private for
reviewing the course material and
helping me make it the best possible
That's all folks